Yeah, that's great. Now, let's touch some blockchain. We need to go to the next
Step in our guide and we need to create a wallet for our miner
And then we will use the same commands here paste
Okay, you can just enter just press enter. We'll leave the default path and
Enter the name of the wallet. I will name it miner
Enter the name of the hotkey
I will just press enter and will it will leave the name of the hotkey is default and choose the number of words
Here I need to come up with some password
It could be whatever you want, but just be sure that you remember what this password is
I will just use one two three four four three two one and press enter one more time
Press enter, okay
Okay, that's great. Please be sure that you save that your password is one
one two three four four three two one my password plus
word
Miner and be sure that you stored this first phrase. You can just copy it cold key
Like this cold key is right and you save the hotkey hotkey is
Okay, so this is very important step you need to store this phrase to be able to restore this wallet afterwards
Here is some background information. What is wallet? Why would you use this and
What is mnemonic phrase you can take a pause and and
early this
Okay. Now we need to get the faucet tokens. We need to get the testnet tau tokens for this particular blockchain and
Here you can ask me and I will send it to you, but you need to know how to ask
There is going to be specific instruction how to ask for the tokens
you need to
To make this BTC live
VW mean wallet least command. Okay, let me clear it up since we saved everything
This is a live wallet list
Okay, and we can see that in our system. There is actually one wallet its name minor
the hotkey is default and
This is the addresses of the cold key and hotkey and what you need to do
you need to
copy this
You need to copy this
address and
You can save it here and also I encourage you to save
Everything here, let's just save it and what you need to do you need to send to me
This cold key address. You just need to copy it and send it to me
Okay, I will take a pause here. I will fill up this wallet and I will come back to you. Oh before before I
Before I go we can check the balance on these
On this wallet. Let me show you that it's empty right now
Enter the wallet name. Okay, the word name is minor
It's retrieving balance from the blockchain from the net and we can see that unfortunately I I'm poor right now
Right, but okay, let me take a pause and I will fill up this wallet
Okay, so what I've done here since on my personal wallet. I'm a
This testnet tower whale I have bunch of them
I just transferred it from my personal wallet as I will do with you to the
Wallet that I created for the minor and you can see here. I use the same BTSI wallet balance command
I will just put that I want to know the balance for the minor and
As you can see here my balance is now more than zero. Yeah, this is this is good
Now I have some money to do things
Okay, what is our next step next step is to register this wallet onto the subnet itself
We can also call to this command and with this comment
We will just tell the subnet that hey, there is a minor and he want to participate in the activities
Do you want to continue? I put y as yes
Put my enter my password and the password is as we remember 1 2 3 4
3 2 1 the hardest one
But yeah, what we do here
We just say to the subnet means our entire application and when we tell it on
Using the blockchain that hey, here's the minor that it what that wants to participate in the activities on your subnet
Okay
Yeah, it will take some time also take a pause here
Okay, it's done. So here is also important information that you need to save we can see the logs
that them this minor wallet was registered on the net you ID 1 8 3 with
Unique you ID of 12. So please also store this phrase
To your document where you stored your mnemonic and
addresses
So registered. Okay, this is this is what we need to have in the end for this minor wallet and
Yeah, we can check that this wallet was registered using this
Minor we can see some locks. Yeah, if I if I
It will show more information here
Yeah, we can see that this minor was registered on this subnet 8 1 3
With the UID number 12. Okay, I will take a pause here and I will continue
after